it has been lovely to see everyone it
really has
it's been a long time since i've seen
any of them
it's just been a joy getting to relive
it all
take a trip down the memory lanes folks
[Music]
so it's rather strange to be back here
at least then to be honest with you it's
been a while and it's been great seeing
everyone
i think this is the perfect time to sit
down with everyone and reminisce
we get the chance to hang out with each
other which has been a real privilege
being in the great hall with everyone
early was just incredible
you see everyone's faces and it's just
lovely to be here and to share this
anniversary together it's been really
special we could kind of celebrate and
just enjoy being together it's been
lovely seeing everyone again and going
like oh yeah we're all doing great it's
a weird experience because you met them
as kids obviously they've grown up as
they should have and it'd be really
weird if they were still the same age
[Music]
all the memories of working here come
flooding back it's like it was last week
it doesn't feel like 10 years ago at all
the whole studio is obviously much more
glossy than when we filmed on it so it
feels different so you used to build
rolls-royce aero engines here apart from
that it was just sheds it wasn't
soundproofed or anything we pretty much
heard everything that's going on around
the studios were leaky and they were
very makeshift it was not ideal shooting
situation but we loved it we had a great
time it's the greatest playground in the
world
the fact that there's people who've
traveled from all over the planet to
come to where we are right now because
they love potter it's just incredible
it's pretty cool to see that the potter
flame is not being doused at any time
soon all of us on the set were as big of
fans as you could find outside the
studio it's a really important part of
all of our lives to be on the sets and
kind of live it for real was just an
absolute dream
i've just been pleasantly surprised by
people enjoying everything that we made
and that we created there's so much of
life to take in that happened to those
10 years every part of my life is
connected to potter and you've seen even
more how much it means to people and
what a part of people's lives it is it
means even more now and i'm able to
appreciate how special that is
[Music]
you